[Music]
hugh jackman has many talents such as
singing
dancing acting and fighting with giant
blades that shoot out of his knuckles
he's such a versatile actor you could be
forgiven for forgetting at least a few
of his many movies
but if you've been trying to get through
his entire portfolio or you like movies
packed with literary monsters redone
with the side of camp
there is a hugh jackman movie crushing
it on netflix internationally
that needs to go straight onto your
watch list van helsing came out in 2004
in the hugh jackman timeline we are all
blessed to be living in
that's between the second and third
x-men movies in the movie jackman plays
a vampire hunter
fans of the novel dracula may remember
but in a very different vein than the
original incarnation
the movie did respectably well at the
box office when it was released
in fact it made nearly twice its budget
but it never achieved the same sequel
worthy status as other monster movie
reboots like brendan fraser's the mummy
in fairness the lack of a follow-up for
van helsing may have partly
come down to jackman's extremely tight
schedule but those who saw and
appreciated van helsing know that it
should have received the same level of
appreciation as other popcorn franchises
that came out around the same time
and maybe it will now that it's been
resurrected on streaming
full disclosure jackman's title
character doesn't just turn vampires
which is a key reason this movie is so
fun he works for the vatican hunting all
sorts of unholy monsters that have
popped up in unholy literature over the
centuries bless me father friend
yes after dispatching mr hyde van
helsing is sent to transylvania to help
the last remaining member of the cursed
valeria's family
fight off a scourge of vampires not just
any vampires this is count dracula and
his three brides plus the thousands of
baby vampires they're working to create
with a machine made by a mad scientist
but the last member of the valeria's
family anna doesn't want van helsing's
help in taking out the threat
at least at first the story takes many
twists each of them introducing new
monsters and unlikely magical scenarios
and
great fight scene set pieces spoiler
alert there's also frankenstein
and an unexceptionally over the top
twist he turns out to play a key role in
vampire reproduction
yup sounds crazy but it all makes sense
within van helsing's wild continuity
like we said earlier van helsing landed
right in the middle of hugh jackman's
original wolverine era when the actor's
best traits were his fight moves
quips and trademark silliness the
character in van helsing is surprisingly
similar if a little more soulful
he is one of the vatican's dark secrets
after all if you love watching hugh
jackman bring his unique brand of
impossibly proportioned muscles
to choreographed stunts and fights with
this winning aussie charm tacked on as a
bonus
you will definitely find something to
enjoy in van gaal sing
even if you're less a hugh jackman fan
than you are a monster movie fan
the chances are high that van helsing is
your kind of movie
it's written and directed by steven
summers who also wrote and directed the
underrated adventure films the mummy
and the mummy returns and it pays homage
to the old monster movies of the 30s and
40s
with as much relish as those other
action classics the monsters per minute
ratio is also even higher in van helsing
than it is in the mummy
so if you enjoyed summer's other monster
projects you'll like this too
really the only people who probably
wouldn't enjoy van helsing
are those who can't bear to see literary
monsters reinterpreted for a new
audience and such a radical violent way
this movie is over the top pays to keep
you interested and about as fun as you'd
think
battling hundreds of baby vampires with
an automated crossbow that shoots stakes
like a machine gun would be
it's exactly as fun as that check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about forgotten
movies and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you